merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre samedi dernier la Guyane s'est
réveillé sous le choc Arnaud blanc
maréchal des logis chef de l'antenne
locale du GIGN a été tué lors d'une
opération de lutte contre leur paillage
illégal nos pensées d'ailleurs vont à sa
famille ses proches ainsi qu'à ses
frères d'armes ce drame intervient
quelques jours après que des hommes
armés de mitrailleuses kalachnikov ont
braqué un autre site d'orpaillage et en
pris en otage le personnel et un pilote
d'hélicoptère ces incidents sont les
conséquences d'une forte augmentation de
l'empaillage illégal mais aussi de la
présence de factions en provenance du
Brésil nous ne sommes pas au bout de nos
peines en effet depuis son investiture
le président Lula a déclaré la guerre à
leur paillage clandestin au Brésil ainsi
près de 20 000 garennes Perros ont été
chassés de la réserve yanomanie on
estime à 5000 le nombre d'employeurs
illégaux qui pourraient ainsi rejoindre
la Guyane et porter à 11000 le
contingent de un chercheur d'or illégaux
sur notre territoire pour ne rien
arranger sur les marchés internationaux
le cours de l'or ne cesse de s'envoler
ces dernières semaines rendant les
sous-sols de la Guyane plus attractifs
que jamais vous connaissez monsieur le
ministre les enjeux environnementaux et
sécurité auquel est confronté la Guyane
en 2017 le président de la République
lui-même avec conditionné nos aides et
nos relations diplomatiques avec le
Brésil et le Suriname à une coopération
policière et judiciaire contre leur
paillage illégal 6 ans plus tard et
malgré les opérations harpies leur
paillage illégal demeure un fléau hors
de contrôle c'est pourquoi monsieur le
ministre je souhaiterais connaître
précisément les mesures que vous
entendez prendre pour intensifier
l'action de l'État en matière de lutte
contre l'Empire illégal préserver
l'intégrité du territoire guyanais
protéger les populations guyanaises et
préserver l'environnement je vous
remercie merci et je veux avoir comme
vous au nom de la première ministre et
du gouvernement
une pensée pour la famille et pour le
sacrifice du maréchal et le logis chef
blanc militaire du GIGN très rompu à
l'exercice et qui a trouvé effectivement
la mort sans doute assassiné l'enquête
le dira par ce que vous dénoncez
permettez-moi aussi d'avoir une pensée
pour les sapeurs-pompiers de Paris qui
connaissent au moment où je parle un
accident extrêmement grave de la route
en Guyane là aussi avec plusieurs
pronostics vital engagés je sais que je
parle au nom de la représentation
nationale en associant évidemment
je veux dire madame la sénatrice que la
lutte de la France
contre leur paillage illégal est une
lutte pour la souveraineté bien sûr une
lutte contre les trafics de tout genre
et une lutte contre l'insécurité qui
touche de compatriotes guyanais vous
l'avez dit vous-même ces bandes armées
qui pillent le sol de la Guyane qui
polluent parce que c'est la protection
de l'environnement qui est évidemment en
jeu mais qui ensuite revendent et
ensuite vont dans les villes de Guyane
et bien sûr à Cayenne mais pas
simplement faut aussi naître les
augmentations d'homicides et de
tentatives de médecine que votre
collectivité connaît depuis trop
longtemps alors le gouvernement a
augmenté les moyens 250 policiers
gendarmes depuis 6 ans l'opération
Harpie civil au militaire gendarmerie
nationale mais également de l'armée je
parle aussi au nom bien sûr de Sébastien
Lecornu a été renouvelé sous le
président Hollande parce qu'elle avait
été imaginé en 2008 et renouvelé ce
président Macron en 2018 et je sais
qu'autour de la première ministre nous
réfléchissons à renforcer des moyens
notamment militaires dans le cas de la
loi de programmation militaire qui vous
sera bientôt proposé pour prendre en
compte le nouveau deal et brésilien que
vous évoquez la protection de la plus
grande frontière qu'à la France a qu'un
pays étranger c'est-à-dire le Brésil
évidemment tenir la protection de la
forêt amazonienne avec toutes les
difficultés que nous connaissons le
sacrifice du militaire du GIGN ne ce
n'est pas 20 il est évidemment comme
tous ces autres camarades un soldat de
la protection de nos frontières de nos
compatriotes guyanais ce n'est pas
simplement pour protéger une forêt c'est
déjà beaucoup qui est militaire du GIGN
sont dans la forêt amazonienne en Guyane
c'est pour protéger évidemment
l'aiguille année dérèglement de compte
extrêmement nombreux que nous
connaissons depuis de trop nombreux mois